Nos dicen que: "Un globo meteorológico que
contiene 1.85 x 10³ L de gas helio a 23°C y
765 Torr se lanza a la atmósfera. El globo viaja
durante dos horas antes de explotar a una altitud
de 32 kilómetros donde la temperatura es -44°C y
la presión es 6.51 Torr. ¿Cuál es el volumen del
globo justo antes de explotar?" Pausa el video
y trata de resolverlo. Muy bien, quizás tengas
un sentido intuitivo y sepas que esto tiene algo
que ver con la Ley de los gases ideales, porque
nos están dando una gran cantidad de presiones,
volúmenes y temperaturas, y la Ley de los gases
ideales trata con esto, pues dice que la presión
multiplicada por el volumen es igual al número de
moles por la constante de los gases ideales por
la temperatura [PV = nRT]. Ahora, lo que tiene
en particular este ejemplo es que no sólo nos
están dando varias de estas variables pidiéndonos
resolver una de ellas, nos están diciendo que
estas variables cambian y cómo eso podría afectar
a otras variables. Así que una forma de pensar
en esto es dividir ambos lados entre T para
obtener PV / T = nR. Y en este ejemplo, mientras
este globo va a altitudes cada vez más altas,
la cantidad de moles no cambia y la constante
de los gases ideales no cambia, entonces podemos
pensar que PV / T tiene que ser constante; de modo
que nuestro volumen y nuestra temperatura podrían
cambiar, pero debido a que toda esta expresión de
la izquierda tiene que ser constante eso podría
determinar nuestra presión. Otra forma de pensar
en esto es que la presión inicial multiplicada
por el volumen inicial sobre su temperatura
inicial va a ser igual a la cantidad de moles por
la constante de los gases ideales, que también
debe ser igual a la presión justo antes de que
explote por el volumen justo antes de que explote,
dividido entre la temperatura justo antes de que
explote, o podríamos decir que P₁V₁ / T₁ = P₂V₂
/ T₂. ¿Y en qué son diferentes estas variables?
Bueno, pensemos primero en P₁. ¿A cuánto es igual
la presión en el primer momento? Es igual a 765
Torr -765 Torr-, ¿y cuánto es P₂? Es la presión
justo antes de que explote, y nos dicen que es
igual a 6.51 Torr, una presión mucho menor, lo que
tiene sentido intuitivo: estamos a mayor altitud,
6.51 Torr. Ahora, ¿cuánto es V₁? Bueno, nos dicen
que es 1.85 x 10³ L. Ahora, ¿cuánto es V₂? Bueno,
eso es lo que nos piden que calculemos, "¿cuál es
el volumen del globo justo antes de explotar?" Así
que pondré un pequeño signo de interrogación aquí.
Y luego, por último pero no menos importante,
¿cuánto es T₁? Bueno, nos dicen que la temperatura
inicial de 23°C, pero tienes que pensar en una
escala más absoluta y lidiar con las temperaturas
en términos de Kelvin. Para convertir 23°C en
grados Kelvin tienes que sumar 273, entonces
éstos serán 296 Kelvin. Y ¿cuánto es T₂? Bueno,
T₂ es -44°C; si le sumamos 273, veamos eso va
a ser 229 K. De modo que tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos para resolver V₂, de hecho podemos
resolver V₂ incluso antes de poner estos números.
Si multiplicamos ambos lados de esta ecuación
por T₂ / P₂, y la razón por la que lo estoy
multiplicando así es para cancelar esto con esto,
y esto se cancela con esto, así que sólo queda V₂
del lado derecho. Por supuesto que tengo que hacer
esto en ambos lados, T₂ / P₂. Ahora lo codificaré
con colores. Voy a obtener T₂P₁V₁ / P₂T₁ = V₂.
Así que ahora sólo tenemos que calcular esto.
Y podríamos escribir que V₂ = T₂
que es 229 K multiplicado por P₁
que es 765 Torr por V₁ que es 1.85 x 10³
L, y todo esto sobre P₂ que es 6.51 Torr,
por T₁ que es 296 K. Y podemos confirmar que las
unidades funcionan: Torr se cancela con Torr,
Kelvin se cancela con Kelvin y así sólo vamos
a tener todos estos números para el cálculo,
y las unidades que nos quedan son litros, lo
cual es bueno porque es lo que nos importa cuando
queremos saber el volumen. Así que esto es igual
a 229 x 765 multiplicado por 1.85 x 10³ / 6.51
/ 296 es igual a este número que tenemos aquí.
Veamos: aquí tenemos tres cifras significativas,
aquí tenemos tres cifras significativas, tres
aquí, tres aquí y tres aquí, entonces nuestra
respuesta tendrá tres cifras significativas,
por lo que si redondeamos serán 168,000,
y entonces podríamos escribir eso como 168,000
litros, o si queremos escribirlo en mutación
científica podríamos escribirlo como 1.68 x 10
elevado a la 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, a la quinta potencia,
así que déjenme escribirlo de esa manera: 1.68 x
10⁵ potencia litros. Siempre me gusta revisar la
intuición, eso tiene sentido, nuestro volumen
inicial fue de 1,850 litros y luego nuestro
volumen se hizo más grande, porque la altitud
era mayor y eso tiene sentido intuitivo para mí.